is this art or is it racism an
exhibition that's been shown in 12 other
cities around the world has been shut
down in London before it even began on
its opening night protesters surrounded
exhibit b an installation by a white
South African artist it features black
actors shackled and chained in cages and
claims to explore the legacy of slavery
and racial oppression but only a handful
of people were able to see it with
protesters forcing the doors closed
because of the protest and for the
protestors there's a real sense of
victory the Barbican says it could not
guarantee the safety of those involved
but speaking to Sky News beforehand it
defended the show people feel that this
show is somehow racist it isn't it is a
very important exploration of issues
surrounding racism it draws on the human
zoos of previous centuries freak shows
in which people seen as abnormal were
displayed black people amongst them one
with Sarah Baartman
a slave known as Hottentot Venus who
entertained European audiences in the
1800s this dancer who took part in
Exhibit B in Paris says she tried to put
on something similar herself but found
little interest in her perspective where
white people can do it they can choose
to do it and and the program matters
take them take the project because they
say they are more
distant to do it and the black people
they never take the project because we
don't have enough distance to do it and
I can understand the black people will
be fed up with this Exhibit B has now
been cancelled but the Rao over where
freedom of expression ends and racism
begins continues fo Hirsch Stein news